everyone's me Gina and I have with me
the beautiful the sexiest the fattest so
I have David here today he's going to be
helping me to my my boyfriend does my
makeup tag me please not my boyfriend
but who's that she wishes we tried good
eye sprawled out all my makeup here for
him and I would explain to him what each
and every one is and then he's gonna
hopefully make me look beautiful
I have absolutely no makeup on right now
for those who want to see that makeup is
happening it's not that great easy I
[ __ ] up canvases beautiful scope what
kind of it's this fence aiming hearing
it's like oh ah
remember kids take your [ __ ] then don't
wash your hands first
no hold still and then what you're going
to do is massage the temples and then
wow it's making what is with this color
so I remember as you can see the face
was ugly as [ __ ] before and we are on a
good track yup you may wish you to touch
like this right it's not that great but
what we's doing it on a cut you got
visited Gina Gina
multiple times by the time multiple and
this is the only way she got me to touch
her so she's good I don't date men who
have bigger breasts than I do I do like
her mustache oh good
there we go hold still oh no oh I feel
like I'm being molested by like a fat
pedophile face was better before now we
had to add the bareMinerals
yeah [ __ ] it now I don't know where to
start up close your [ __ ] eyes this
you hurt no there's a specific whoa it's
getting everywhere oh so nothing I feel
like a big hefty clumsy idiot like him
it's a very soft touch is it a [ __ ]
touch so what we're going to do I start
off what the [ __ ] oh no no no no no no
no this is not make this possible is it
why the [ __ ] are they
it's [ __ ] stupid oh my god
give me that little cocktail on your
face but yeah where'd you learn that
Hey holy [ __ ] don't fix you that that's
all then do it then you know this thing
does it look
next we are going to do okay that's
mascara we're gonna do that up okay
don't poke me I'm definitely I would I
do you see how steady his head I just
fit right in my [ __ ] baby let's go to
spit in my face you know I feel like my
skin are you coloring my lashes are my
eyelids why don't you shut the [ __ ] up
for a second and let me do my job
all right oh my god oh my god this is
Carrie a woman's face
you're vicious ins the ugly [ __ ] back is
beautiful [ __ ] don't worry about it
you're like [ __ ] Asian Bob Ross right
now [ __ ] fob loss no real lasting
eyeliner am I supposed to call it no
it's his eyeliner it's like I've been
lying on my bed wall that's [ __ ]
difficult close your [ __ ] eyes
I love your nails
oh my god
it's y'all are that's where girls get
ready it's just [ __ ] hard right now
we've been behind honey Oh buddy here we
go we want to do this we'll play
did you miss a spot on your mustache
pelisek one strand they grow randomly
more the biggest let's clear this leg
straight stripper glitter here morons
awesome oh [ __ ] you look [ __ ] hot yet
oh [ __ ] Hulu doing your finger 3 so
clumsy having sausage fingers hold on
jello oh [ __ ] ain't that bad yo yeah
sweet let's listen this first question
okay
the top of this top part is good though
you can make a listing there you go cat
dude JC that [ __ ] Daisy
it looks fun good
that snack it looks together and next
when you put the eyeliner on the left
what so for those of you who want to get
a third you got to make sure you outline
your lips now we have to add the
finishing touches
also just disclosure eyes oh I know what
I'm doing
oh my god what are you doing
I know what and then there's the X
actuate for natural beauty and everybody
needs a Cindy Crawford move so okay they
call this a beauty mark to top it off
the final touch the focus is what we
doing a joint gang signs on my face I am
drunk a signs and perfect okay
she looks beautiful let's give you this
small knot and go oh you don't want to
run out for this no not bad see dictum
at home with us actually you're pretty
good are we I hope since I want you to
get molded
his hair what that's what your big hair
looks like that is the most [ __ ] up
eyeliner ever I thought it's really
difficult I realized how hard listen to
actually probably you know what my face
actually doesn't look at that what I'm
saying see what you people don't realize
is that I'm very observant it's gonna be
a lot of most most comedians are so you
know when I look at a woman's face as a
lot of you men know when you when you're
with them and when you wake them when
you wake up within the next day thanks
David
you [ __ ] you look believable on the
mess make sure